A good friend of mine once said
the price of freedom is high
where do we start people need the symbol they
need a cap
where do we start
sweet jesus i mean how old are you
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
falcon and winter soldier trailer video they just
dropped a new trailer with a bunch of new marvel
easter eggs i'll talk about the connections to
what's happening on Wandavision because there'll
be a little bit of crossover in what's happening
and some of the bigger things that they're
setting up for marvel phase four just in general
because obviously everything's connected
the series are supposed to influence what's
happening in the movies and in the way that
Wandavision is helping set up doctor strange 2
spider-man 3 in the marvel x-men mutants in
the mcu falcon and winter soldier will also
set up a bunch of other different stuff too so
we'll talk about thunderbolts red hulk weapon x
all the big stuff that's coming up of course i'll
be doing videos for all the episodes so be sure to
subscribe if you're brand new to my channel and
we'll do the disney plus giveaways every week
during that as well too also for those of you that
like longer episodes because Wandavision episodes
have been around 20 to 30 minutes long falcon
and winter soldier episodes are supposed to be
closer to 40 42 minutes long war machine is gonna
cameo during the falcon winter soldier episodes
so just like they're leading into weapons plus
because of what happened during the five year time
jump they'll also probably help set up what's
going on during the armor war series which is
basically going to be the war machine series
taking place next year don cheadle didn't say how
many episodes he's going to be in he just said
he's going to show up during falcon and winter
soldiers so we'll just find out when we actually
start getting those but the new trailer footage
begins with just more their funny buddy cop
rivalry on the plane than falcon's voiceover he's
quoting captain america from way back during the
captain america winter soldier movie it was when
he hijacked the com system to reveal hydra's plan
to all the shield agents in the triskelion asking
them for his help to stop hydra and launching the
new helicarriers with artem zola's algorithm this
is the full scene of him talking about the price
of freedom in context and what that actually meant
if you launch those helicarriers today hydra will
be able to kill anyone that stands in their way
unless we stop them
i know i'm asking a lot the price of freedom
is high it always has been and it's a price i'm
willing to pay but the way they're using the quote
during falcon and winter soldier it means almost
the same thing it's about how far falcon and bucky
are willing to go in pursuit of justice that was
a little more cut and dry during the winter
soldier movie even though that was a thriller
plot like you're like wait a minute what's going
on this guy's my friend i need to save him i can't
take him down but you have all the hydra stuff
so we knew who the bad guys were like oh hydra
is the bad guy this time though after avengers
end game the threat is a little more insidious
because it's all about thunderbolt ross the us
government hijacking the captain america mantle
and legacy in addition to all the baron zemo stuff
the way they're positioning the baron zemo terror
plot and all the trailer footage about him trying
to destroy all superheroes they shouldn't exist
he's meant to be the obvious villain of the series
but because the series is largely inspired by
the tone and the action of the winter soldier
movie you're meant to question authority and
they're just picking up on what's happening with
thunderbolt ross and the government after avengers
end game and that's where we get to the connection
between what's happening on Wandavision in the
falcon winter soldiers series the connection
is through what sword and tyler hayward are
doing or were doing up to this point turning sword
into a sentient weapons program and organization
militarizing what basically used to be a shield
version of nasa as we've learned from tyler
hayward during the Wandavision episodes after
the snap in avengers infinity war everyone that
survived in the government the military freaked
out every single agency like sword what's left of
shield it kind of still exists but not really in
the mcu thunderbolt ross who's still in charge of
the world security council they all double down
on militarizing everything and i believe that
thunderbolt ross was not snapped so he had five
years to go way more hardcore than he was before
infinity war within sword we saw that they were
trying to reactivate vision and use his technology
to develop more sentient weapons a lot of you
actually asked me now if i think that that's them
setting up the concept for the x-men sentinels in
the mcu like through this sentient weapons program
it's totally possible Wandavision is supposed
to lay some track work for mutants in the mcu
as we've seen with monica rambo getting her dna
mutated by the hex turning her into a version
of spectrum from the comics but the way this all
affects thunderbolt ross and the events of falcon
and winter soldier is that the military basically
reactivates the super soldier program through
the weapons plus program that thunderbolt ross
created he talked about that during the incredible
hulk movie but part of the actual synopsis for
the series early on was that bucky and falcon
learned that someone is trying to reactivate
the weapons plus program and that's only part
of the plot as you've seen in the trailer footage
that's totally true because we're getting the us
agent version of captain america like the flyers
from inside the actual episode say cap is back
but it's not steve rogers captain america they're
talking about it's the us agent version of cap
who we finally get some more footage of in the
trailer in his actual costume with the shield
this is him kneeling down inside this warehouse
weirdly they've been holding back on footage of
him like yeah we know what's going on we know
this is all about us agent captain america the
whole conflict there being that old man steve
rogers passed the mantle to falcon in the shield
and thunderbolt ross is probably like oh hell no
i own the rights to that shield i represent the
government the government owns that shield he
had such a contentious relationship with steve
rogers captain america and he wants a symbol to
rally people around a symbol that he can control
like a dog of war that he can just unleash around
the world when he wants problems taken care of
so more wanda vision connections thunderbolt ross
is basically doing the same thing tyler hayward
and sword were doing but with the captain america
and super soldiers the darkest timeline versions
of captain america that's what some of the footage
of all the soldiers lining up in their dress
uniforms is about like they're just sort of hyping
up that there's a new program that they reactivate
and they're looking for candidates for the next
captain america and it just winds up being u.s
agent that they land on there more scenes of
winter soldier training falcon how to throw
the shield correctly so that it returns to you
nice callback to all the times that he used the
shield himself during the winter soldier movie
and captain america civil war when they were
tag teaming iron man fun fact too the working
title while they were filming falcon and winter
soldier was tag team but that's because obviously
they're giving off so much riggs and murtaugh
lethal weapon energy during this all these agents
walking down the staircase might be the same ones
from earlier in the other trailers those might be
either the german police force or from the czech
republic it's a little hard to tell just from the
badges on their shoulders but i believe it's meant
to be the same group the series will have them
traveling all over the world but a lot of places
in eastern and western europe like a lot of the
scenes take place in germany like this fight scene
with what looks like us agent because there's
this big german sign in the warehouse and it
looks like it's connected to the footage of falcon
holding the shield while he's wearing his costume
like either they're both there trying to take
someone down or they get into a fight themselves
with the shield but the whole idea is that baron
zemo is traveling all over the world with the
flag smashers so they're chasing him all over the
world there's footage from all over the place but
a lot of the trailer footage is specific to what's
happening in madra poor which is a big x-men comic
book location port of call for marvel villains so
to speak just a lot of shady stuff goes on there
the official synopsis for the series that they
have on the wiki right now has them trying
to stop the anti-governmental group the flag
smashers but the way they're positioning baron
zemo and all this trailer footage makes it seem
like he's using the flag smashers as his pawns
i know there's a lot of questions about there
maybe being multiple versions of captain america's
shielder in the trailer like does the government
thunderbolt ross try to fabricate another second
shield for us agent the way it looks in all
the trailer footage it looks like the exact
same shield so it's kind of hard to tell because
the trailer footage is kind of broken up from
all the different episodes like if you go back
and you watch the Wandavision trailers there's
footage from the final Wandavision episodes like
episodes eight and nine in the very first trailers
that they released so it's probably the same
deal with the falcon and winter soldier trailers
there's probably footage here from later in the
episodes and from the very beginning of the series
so it sounds like falcon probably doesn't get the
shield back for good until towards the end of the
series and for a big portion early on it's
us agent walking around with captain america
shield i'm not completely sold on the multiple
shields theory until we see some more footage
but a lot of you've also asked me because they're
trying to set up weapons plus will we also see
them trying to set up the concept of adamantium
during the series because u.s scientists created
adamantium when they were trying to fabricate
more vibranium adamantium is a vibranium alloy
basically what happened is is u.s scientists
tried to combine vibranium with steel and it
wound up turning into adamantium the difference
between the two is that vibranium is just better
at absorbing kinetic damage but adamantium
is a much denser material so that's why in
most fights why wolverine's claws for example
are capable of scratching captain america's
shield but given enough force like extreme force
adamantium weapons could cut through vibranium
but it would take someone as strong as like thanos
or the hulk or thor wielding a vibranium weapon
to do that they tried to hike that up during
avengers end game when thanos was using his giant
double-bladed sword to attack captain america's
shield and basically cut it almost in half thanos
weapon wasn't adamantium though it was actually
uru metal it's the same metal that's used to make
all the asgardian weapons like stormbreaker
thor's hammer mjolnir all their armor as for
thunderbolts easter eggs red hulk set up it just
sounds like that's all going to be happening in
the background i'm not expecting to legit see red
hulk show up during this series i think they'll
probably save something like that for a dedicated
hulk project like she-hulk or something later on
remember the avengers age of ultron post
credit scene with thanos where he says
fine i'll do it myself i feel like we're going to
get a similar moment with thunderbolt ross at some
point like all these people have failed me all
these programs that i've been trying to create
fine i'll do it myself and he puts himself
through a version of the weapons plus program
the early theory with thunderbolts though is that
by the end of the series they'll finally capture
baron zemo they won't kill him but thunderbolt
ross will come to him offering him a deal we'll
give you time off your sentence if you help join
our program here i'm putting together a team
the whole thing with the thunderbolts in the mcu
is they're basically a version of marvel's suicide
squad and the reason why thunderbolt ross would
do that is because he hates superheroes just as
much as baron zemo talks about during the trailer
superheroes should not exist because thunderbolt
ross can't control any of the superheroes he
can't control the avengers but he does need an
expendable group of very powerful individuals
to do his dirty work so once we start getting
falcon winter soldier episodes i'll start pointing
out thunderbolts easter eggs as we start seeing
them like which people are going to be on that
first version of the team i'll talk more about
young avengers stuff after we get the Wandavision
finale too but everyone post all your theories
about falcon and winter soldier in the comments
below we'll get more trailers before the series
drops but what's going to happen in a couple weeks
is we'll get the Wandavision finale then the week
after that there'll be a special bonus episode for
that and then the week after that is when we get
falcon and winter soldier episode one and we're
actually getting the justice league snyder cut
the night before falcon and winter soldier episode
1 drops so i'm going to be pretty busy that week
as long as you have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll see all those videos though leave all your
requests for bonus videos too if you have any
big questions or there any easter eggs in the
trailers that you saw that i didn't talk about
during the video congratulations anessi mayabi
you're the giveaway winner from my last big wanda
vision video please email me on the about page of
my channel so i can get your contact details
while you wait for everything click here for
my Wandavision post credit scene video in episode
8 trailer and click here for my full Wandavision
episode 7 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!